first of all let's
see can you guys see me and hear me I
hope
so let's see if this is
working
um thank you very much for being uh
coming here first of all and um it's
practically we are in 2024 so um I hope
that your 2023 has gone really well and
you're excited and pumped up for for a
wonderful
2024 um one thing I wanted to tell you
I'm going to try to answer like as
always there's a lot of uh questions and
I always try to go uh you know try to
answer as many as possible but uh of
course I have
limits um so what I'm going to do is I'm
gonna again G to try to check uh the
chat try to answer all your uh all your
questions um and uh but before before uh
I do that I get into the questions all
the wonderful questions um I wanted to
make an
announcement uh and I'm going to post it
here let's see if you can see it in the
chat basically uh I have written another
book now I don't know maybe some of you
know that I have already a book an ebook
um that um you can find on my website
you can purchase on my website uh but in
the last three months I've been working
with my team on a book on another book
another ebook that you can download
completely for free it's more than 80
Pages um and you can you can download
the entire package and UB PDF and an
audiobook and uh it's a 90minut
audiobook
so uh I think you're going to like that
there's a lot of stuff uh you know it's
practically another book that I've
written and it's all for you to um uh to
read and listen to the only thing you
need to do is to go to the website to my
website and sign up for sign up to the
newsletter and um in a few minut minutes
you will get the package I will talk
about this also in the middle of the
session and also at the end as usual so
um let me check um okay let me go up to
the bunch of uh questions but before I
address the questions in the chat I
wanted to address two very interesting
um question questions I was asked you
cannot see this probably so very big
light pointing at me there that keeps
you from seeing this but I'm going to
read it for you Marco but I'm gonna read
these two from uh from Instagram and
then the rest from YouTube uh Marco asks
I practice three languages every day so
I I'm learning three languages every day
should I spend more of my time with the
language I invest in because it's easier
and less exhausting or should I invest
the most of my time into my weakest
language because it needs the most work
what are your thoughts on this um thank
you and
greetings sorry about that greetings
from Germany I always say that when it
comes to learning three languages at the
same time in my case I'm gonna I'm gonna
start learning four from the beginning
of the year um it's like having a you
know an extended family there's one more
member that joins the the family the
newborn and I always think that the uh
newest language is the newborn and it
really needs the the most attention so
yes it's true that the language you
speak the best in which you have the
best level is the easiest to learn or
the less exhausting but I do believe
that you should structure things so that
you can uh first tackle the language
that needs the most attention and it
also needs the most concentration that's
what I would do I would order it in
terms of what is a language that I know
the worst what is the newest language
I'll G to tackle that first first thing
in the morning and then I'm going to do
the the second one and I'm GNA do the
third that's my
answer um and paa G asks me always from
um
uh on Instagram promise I'm going to get
back to you guys um my question is how
can I manage learning a new language
with others that I've already known
because my feeling is that I lose the I
lose the other languages if I focus my
efforts on a new one I like to learn
German but I'm afraid that my French
gets
worse um well uh when it comes to
learning new languages and maintaining
other languages I always say it's great
to reach at least a B2 level in uh some
of the languages that you speak before
you start learning other ones otherwise
it it's a mess it's always a mess to try
to learn multiple languages at once if
you don't have a level uh where you are
at the very least a language learner
I've already specified this language
learner sorry language user language
user means that you can already use the
language so let's say you've reached a
B2 level by the way I have my computer
here I have MyPad here so I can see so I
can keep a uh I have the top of the you
know the first comment and then I have
the last comments here because otherwise
it's going to be it's going to be a mess
to follow everything so I'm going to try
my best okay so uh now back to you guys
Christian asks that's a very first
comment on top I'm GNA try to go through
uh all the questions one by one the ones
that I deem the most the most relevant
how can I acquire more vocabulary when I
have a B1 level in English well my
answer is very simple make sure that you
consume on a on a daily basis content
that is interesting to you that is
comprehensible that you maybe you can
you know create for example uh bilingual
uh text or you can use vocabul online
dictionaries in order to dissect and
understand the you know the text um or
the the transcription of the podcast or
the subtitles or whatever you're
consuming into your own native language
you can understand it better you make it
comprehensible and then it has to be
slightly challenging this one is
particularly important when it comes to
vocabulary and slightly challenging a
piece of of content that is slightly
challenging basically means a piece of
content that has a number of words that
you do not know but the thing is the
tricky thing is that if there are too
many words that you don't know then it
becomes discouraging so you have to
learn to find yourself in the so-called
gold elock Zone where something is not
too difficult it's not too easy and
maybe for each interesting piece of
content and comprehensible piece of
content that you consume you have a
number of words that you don't know and
that you want to learn this is my simple
suggestion forget about list of words
forget about dictionary just consume
content that is interesting For You
YouTube videos podcasts that have
transcriptions so transcriptions and
subtitles and then use paper if you can
underlying stuff that you like let me
see here also to my left there's a lot
of questions coming so I'm going to try
to you know beat my personal record and
reply to all of all of them it's not
going to happen but it doesn't matter
dude asks what is the Liber practice in
speaking I think the dude has been
asking this question over the last five
or five or six days because I've seen it
everywhere so dude we're finally here I
can answer the question and the the
answer is there's two form let's say to
simplify there's two forms of let's say
practicing speaking in in this
particular context you have deliberate
practice and you have simple practice
simple practice is just talking for the
sake of talking right you're talking to
a friend you're sitting uh you're you're
you're drinking a and you're talking
about whatever in your tur language
deliberate practice in speaking means
that you sit down with a very specific
purpose to give you a very concrete
example it means for example that you're
sitting down and you're talking to a
tutor that you hired or maybe a friend
and that friend is listening to you you
have prepared the lesson in advance
you're talking about a specific topic
and maybe you've prepared some words
some vocabulary within that topic and
that that friend or that tutor is going
to give you some corrections and then
you record the conversation you re
listen to it again and then you learn
from that so there's two different forms
of practice the one is I call it simple
because it's simple to do you just talk
to a friend well the other one is more
complex and it requires more steps it
requires more energy concentration and
planning but it's much more effective
and I always say you have to mix you
have to balance the two because if you
just engage in simple practice then it's
okay but you're not going to make a lot
of progress but if you just um engage in
deliberate practice then you're going to
burn out so you need a little bit of
both so uh Faruk asks which one is more
important speaking immediately or or or
more listening and when would you know
if one is ready to speak one love from
Nigeria I love your content thank you
for I would just say um if you want to
talk if you want to speak just just talk
but I would I would I would always like
in the last 10 years especially I moved
more towards um put listening and
reading listening and reading listening
or reading as much as you can before you
talk depending on the language if a
language is relatively close to mine
maybe the decision of speaking I I can I
can start speaking after three six
months or something like that but if
it's a more distant language it takes
more time I always make sure that I get
a lot of input massive input before
speaking so that's my suggestion but if
you want to talk why
not um let me go now to the um to the
bottom of the list to see what's
happening right now I love you Luka k o
says thank you Janos Fant
mer um let me see here a couple of
questions uh hi Zena says Zena says hi
uh what's your best advice for utilizing
subtitles I like the verb utilizing so
well my best advice is I always put on
subtitles whether I listen to I watch a
movie or a YouTube video in English
Italian Spanish German whatever I always
use
subtitles um if I'm watching the video
uh and especially movies because I think
that subtitles U help you see and listen
at the same time the more channels you
use the best then of course you can
retort that if you look at subtitles
you're not going to enjoy the movie etc
etc but if watching a movie is a
learning experience for you I always
um suggest uh that you use subtitles um
you can use subtitles in English let's
say you're learning French right and
you're a native English speaker then you
can use subtitles in French or you can
use subtitles uh in English or you can
use both you can use a combination of
both when you have for example language
reactor I've made a video about that
where you can actually uh you have a
double script so you can see the
subtitles in both languages the problem
is that you have to learn how to to to
to watch a movie and
uh to concentrate on the subtitles and
extract the information that is training
and the more you do it the the better
there there's much more to say about
subtitles whether to use subtitles in
your target language in your native
language depending on your level but for
now I I hope that this uh this answers
your
question so let me see there's a couple
there's a lot of questions
coming uh let me see let me see um
this is a question in Italian that I'm
going to translate for you guys if you
don't speak Italian basically means Luka
do you think that there's an alternative
way to learn the spoken English that
that is alternative to rather than
talking to um a tutor or to go abroad
well um I would say that um talking to
someone is important if you want to
speak um it's not just a matter of
practicing the language it's also a
matter of uh getting you know confident
and using the language so um I think
that whether it's a tutor a mentor
someone you pay someone you don't pay a
friend um a tandem whatever I think you
have to talk to people because if you
don't talk to people then it's not just
a matter of lack of practice it's a
matter of lack of confidence and for me
fluency is a measure of confidence as I
um as I said in the last video I made
which is are you a language user or a
language
learner so let me go up now I'm going to
go uh you know old messages and and new
messages the same
time um Michael asks Spanish Verbs and
their conjugations are overwhelming what
is the best way to learn them take a
single verb and learn all its forms nope
or learn several verbs in limited number
of forms and and then add Michael the
answer the the simple answer is forget
about all that this is a you know
Paradigm coming the school Paradigm this
is the this formen is this way of
thinking comes from school forget about
you you know even using chat GPT you
don't want to waste your time doing that
have you ever seen a a a Child Learning
their own native language by using
tables conjugations maybe they've
learned about conjugations in school
after five years of a acquiring the
language so kids first acquire then they
learn about the language while we adults
or adults tend to do the exactly the
opposite that's not how it works so you
don't want to do that you just want to
again might sound a little bit boring
but that's the way it works listen and
read as this is the fastest best way to
learn a language uh is to consume
interesting content so you can for
example let's say if you have a B2 B1
level or you have an A2 level consume
content that is at that that level
containing verbs the more the more verbs
you see the
more um your brain is going to pick up
patterns and yes of course you might
still make mistakes but it doesn't
matter we you don't you don't want to
miss the forest for the trees as they
say and this is a way of missing the
forest for the trees focusing on like
conjugations and most of these
conjugations like I you B all you will
not use half of them we always tend to
use I or we or you so I would not go
that right out I would consume a lot of
content that content will contain verbs
I assure you and the more verbs you see
the more forms and and and context the
more verbs in context you
see the more your brain is going to pick
up patterns how long has taken you Agata
Christi I love agat Christi I got a lot
of agat Christi somewhere here um so how
long has taking you from zero to C2
level learning French oh now now the you
know you know the the chat is going
crazy uh French um well the truth is
it's really difficult to answer this
question because I've learned in school
for 10 years and then I met my ex uh
French girlfriend I lived in France I
attended a conference interpreting in
school I think I reached a native like
level after three years of living uh
basically in France and interacting with
people and the language all the time so
it's really difficult to answer because
I started learning French when I was 10
but then after school I didn't do much
for years and then I met my
ex-girlfriend so it it took a it took a
a long time but I think the real
difference uh the real breakthrough or
Watershed whatever you want to call it
what is when in
208 beautiful Prague a beautiful an my
ex-girlfriend I met her and I started
speaking French from that moment and
that propelled me uh through you know
just like I I was completely immersed in
in
in in in the French world literature my
ex-girlfriend's parents loved literature
loved movies I you know just in in a
household where we talked about the
French language all the time in French
with debates and you know just uh um
when we were eating at dinner and it was
amazing anyway so uh let me see
um SAA asks LCA what is your opinion
about holistic approach to the language
learning about the Hol I don't know what
you mean by holistic approach when I
talk about holistic it means that I I
normally when I talk about holistic I
mean that you have to learn all the
parts of language learning uh and that
is important because this way you learn
naturally as kids do if you learn
separately grammar vocabulary etc etc
then that leads to disaster so if you
mean that holistic you mean like a
general Global approach as you know
tackling all the moving parts of a of a
foreign language then the answer is
yes um let me see Sal mer someone said
they love my beard my beard is getting
um is getting white but I'm for I just
turned 43 just you know I'm getting old
so um what have you changed what have
you changed your mind on regarding
language learning in the last five years
this is Alejandro Castello so what is
the thing that for which I guess you
wanted to say you changed your mind
regarding language learning the last
five years um I haven't so much as
Changed My Philosophy I would say that
the one thing in which I I I believe
even formly even more firmly than before
is the importance of input massive input
for your brain for your brain to pick up
patterns this is more and more important
there's a difference between acquiring a
language and learning a language it
might seem the same but it's not the
same acquiring
you know means to learn a language in a
natural way by getting a lot of input
and your brain picks up patterns whether
you're using language learning materials
or you're surrounded by the environment
or both like kids do for example while
learning is sitting down and having try
to figure things out by using Tables by
using explanations Etc I think that both
a combination of both is important we
don't we cannot acquire language like
kids do children do some people say it's
a famous uh input method you just get
input input input and then magically
you're going to be speaking that's true
up to a certain point I'm I lean towards
more like an approach where you have to
balance the capacity of using the
knowledge and the you know that we have
of the world and of our own native
language in order to dissect another
language and then acquire it so first
learn how that works and then you
acquire it later um this is It's called
a weak interface hypothesis if you guys
are interested I talked about that
numerous times this is my stand um and
uh there's uh a lot of literature
talking about the different models of
acquiring language I'm I'm a I'm a
proponent well I'm not the proponent but
when I when I look at all these theories
this is the one that you know um for
which let's say it's a model that
reflects what I do and how I learn
languages and how I train people to
learn languages in my school anyway
let's go back
here uh let's see hey my New Year
resolution is to learn Spanish from
scratch I would like to reach B B1 how
long do you think it will take me I
already speak English as a foreign
language an an um I don't think you
honestly I don't think that's a I mean
it's it's it's a legit it's a legit
legitimate question and but you're
already thinking and worrying about how
long it's going to take you so this is a
mentality of the goal right if you have
a goal then you're always constantly
falling short of the goal every day
right think about that you have a goal
maybe it's going to happen in six months
every day you think oh when is this
going to happen I had a student when I
was giving uh coaching lessons who did
that all the time was asking me when am
I gonna get fluent when am I gonna get
fluent when am I gonna get fluent
sounded like Shrek you know Shrek when
he goes like are we there yet are we
there yet when when Shrek and Fiona go
too far far away so I think you should
shift the the the perspective and
instead of asking this question you
should ask yourself this critical
question what is what can I do every day
in order to learn Spanish for 30 or 45
minutes this is a more critical question
because when you shift from goal to
habits and system you win every day
every day when you do something uh you
tell yourself yes I've done it yeah
right so you have a habit then you do it
and then you win every day and this
creates a reward so instead of thinking
what's my goal yes you can ask yourself
this if you want you can have a goal
like I want to be fluent I want to be
speaking uh Spanish at B1 level in say a
year or in six months let's say or nine
months but even if you have that if you
state that goal if you write it down I
think the most important question then
is transform that goal into a habit ask
yourself what can I do every day to
learn uh Spanish this is the much it's a
much more relevant
question so
um let me see
here I got a lot there's a lot of
questions here
Frank
asks Panama Frank uh basically asks what
can I do to um acquire vocabulary I
think um Frank already asked I already
replied to that question at the
beginning of uh the the live show the
ask Luke anything live show and and
again very suly very briefly you have to
consume a lot of content for the details
you can just uh watch the uh basically
the you know the recording of this uh
you know a little bit later once it's uh
it's online it's it's it's available
online so
um let me see let me see how to learn
English with movies do I have to stop
every time to look up words on Google
can I turn a movie comprehensible that
is too high of My Level junino
asks uh for Pete's sake do not stop
every time to look up words that's
terrible you don't want to do that um
you can use language reactor it's an app
where for example you can watch Netflix
and you can download literally uh the
bilingual transcript of the entire movie
you if you want you can read it before
you watch the movie but if if you watch
a movie and you stop every time to look
up a word it completely disrupts the joy
of uh of watching that movie so maybe
you can watch the movie then you you can
download this bilingual transcript and
then you can watch it again multiple
times rather than stopping every time
this is a this is a big killer let's say
okay let me go up again here um again if
you if I guys skip some of the of the
questions I'm sorry but there are a lot
of them uh Socrates asks
I want to know if you like soccer
football well soccer and what is your
favorite team IA so yes I do like uh
football soccer better said uh but I
don't watch them that often I just watch
the big shows International like champ
champions league but or with my friends
but in general um you know I don't
wantan to I don't want I don't I don't
watch uh sports that much soccer it it
it really depends but in general not
that much Luca I'm really glad you're
here thank you
Michael thank you for the kind words
um Jonathan kirro this rings a bell this
name do you think that learning Talks by
heart is a good strategy to learn
vocabulary or improve one's fluency in
another language no I don't think that
learning anything by heart is a good
strategy I would rather say maybe you
can watch what you can do one thing that
I would suggest is maybe watch on stuff
on YouTube you can um let's say you
watch a a YouTube video for five minutes
of someone talking and then maybe you
can stop it and you try to summarize
what the guy or the girl what whatever
content uh what was said uh during the
video rather than learning things by
heart it depends on what you want to do
again the question is would you want to
improve your speaking then uh I highly
recommend that you summarize you can
maybe listen to watch them watch it or
listen to the movie and then jot down
some keywords and then use those
keywords to summarize so in front of you
you have the piece of paper like this
one that I have here you um joted down
some keywords and then by using those
keywords you can summarize the content
that's a much better much better
exercise in terms of you know developing
your language skills so to
speak so
um Franchesco I've been learning Russian
for three years I have a B2 like level I
want to speak fluently but I don't know
how I've been watching videos with
subtitles for 3 years translating the
unknown words what to do well I my
suggest in Francisco is just to talk to
find some to find someone to talk to and
speak speak as much as you can in real
life or you can you know have a
conversation on one of these uh numerous
platforms that we have nowadays and talk
the more you talk the better you become
that's what I would say um Austin baros
Luka I'm from Argentina greetings Luka
you're from Argentina living current in
K Italy I always watch your videos and
then he says goat thank you thank you
thank you Augustine thank you for the
kind
words uh let me see here um Christian
David Morales Plaza or Christian no Muka
happy New Year in advance happy New Year
back to you and to all of you wonderful
people I speak Portuguese and English
well however I'm a little B shy when I
speak in public in another language
what's your advice to improve that in
readings from Colombia I've talked about
this before speaking
speaking of our language is kind of I
wouldn't go so far as to say it's
complicated it's just that if you do if
you've never done it before then you're
shy about it the more you do it the less
shy the more confident you become you
have to you have to realize that when
you speak a foreign language for the
first time you're combining the new with
the old you're going through situations
you've gone through multiple times in
your life like going to the supermarket
buying a ticket a train ticket or
whatever but now you have to do it in
another language so in a way it's an old
experience that you have to go through
through Le let's say you have to live
and experience through a different lens
and in in in my case the I know that
this sounds a little bit simplistic and
simple but you have to live these
experiences if you want to become
confident speaking of a language fluent
is not just a matter of how many words
you know or how well you know grammar or
how well you pronounce this language
it's mostly about the experiences that
you live so if you're shy if you tell
yourself you're shy the one thing that
can really uh help you is to go out
there and use the language in real life
and you're going to see shyness is going
to melt like snow uh the more you do it
the better easier said than done uh but
uh this is what I suggest so let me see
here there's a bunch of other questions
I'm going to use my iPad I'm moving from
iPad to my
computer uh let's see um floran asks a
very interesting question do you learn a
new language from English as a starting
language or from Italian normally I when
I when I when I start a learning a
foreign language I use the B directional
translation so I use as a language of
reference as my own L1 as I call it my
Italian which is my native language but
if I find a resource that is just in
English just an example of that let me
see if I can find it here there's you
cannot you cannot see it guys but here's
the entire collection
of um
aimal so just to give an example here
let me find another one so when I
started learning
Hungarian this is what I found it's
called Hungarian with ease it was just
in English I can show you here this
is you know what I forget about the mess
here this is about all the stuff that I
use in order to dissect the text
phonetically you can find all this
information in my course by director in
translation for anybody who is
interested it's always in the my school
lc.com but the main point here is that
this is Hungarian English I could not
find anything else so I used English but
I you like the the the content was in
English but I used Italian this one I
use Italian to apply the B dire
translation this is
norish this is like Norwegian I've never
used it but that's what I found back in
the day it's in German so I would have
used German just because it was the
language the only language that was
available but I would have used Italian
when it comes to writing translating
back and forth that's that's my
answer
David um what is your opinion of AI
chatbots like Chad GPT for speaking
practice you know I was talking about
this with my colleague Luca
another Luca and the answer is I don't
have an opinion just as just as yet
because I have never practiced it I've
never I've never practiced talking to a
bot a
bot ER but the I I will tell you more
when I when I try this but the reality
is it could be it could be useful uh I I
don't like chatting I think it's a waste
of time but speaking could be more
interesting but I think um it's going to
be very effective maybe in two three
four years maybe in one year because
technology goes you know advances very
fast but as of now I don't have an
opinion because I've never tried
it
um Osvaldo Caminos when and where would
be the next poly world event it's going
to be in Prague let me see here if I can
uh
polyglots Gathering 2024 let me share
this with you there you
go so it should be
here I don't know if you can see it but
that's uh the next one it's going to be
in Prague in May and it's going to be
interesting
um and then there's going to be a po po
conference as well I think in October or
something like that but they haven't
decided yet when this is going to
happen
so is it possible to learn four
languages at the same time without dying
it's going to be difficult that's what
I'm going to try to do this
year uh but uh we'll see you know I was
just drafting my language learning plan
for 2024 and I just realized that doing
this every day is going to be very very
difficult it's going to be an amazing
very intensive year for me because I
have a lot of
projects uh so we'll see but uh um for
for sure as I said before the newborn
I'm going to take care of the newborn
the new language uh more than anything
uh for the the first three months of the
year and then we'll see it's going to be
difficult anyway and um I I'm a I
consider myself a professional language
professional because this is my job but
don't do this at home I would say four
languages is is a lot unless you have a
lot of time that's what I would say so
maybe two but I always recommend one at
a time that's that's the best
choice so um let me
see uh bog do you think the artificial
intelligence will change how we learn
languages have you tried any of the AI
tools I think I answered this before the
second part of the question and as far
as change uh how we learn language is
fundamentally no but the the strategy is
not fundamentally going to change but
the tactics are going to change so yes
or no I would say it's it's it's a very
long topic but uh we'll see more in the
next months because Chan PT and all this
the stuff is advancing very fast
so saying any tell
um
so let's see uh what if I can't find a
native speaker to practice with what
what program would you recommend you can
always find a native speaker to practice
with if you want uh Globus I think
that's your name so it's difficult to
find a native speaker to talk to in real
life that's possible if you live in
Australia or if you live in in America
if you live in a in a in a place where
these native speakers are not you know
available but you can always find
someone online if you want to uh so prle
for example I talkie um is another one
these are platforms where you can find
uh we can find a lot of people just
these two but you have Camp as well so
if there's a will there's a way as to
say if you want to practice this
language you will find someone to talk
to and that's my recommendation can find
someone in real life find someone online
to talk to because the best way to speak
is just to speak with especially with
someone not just to
yourself
so uh let me see uh
[Music]
um this already replied very excited to
be here Alejandra Flores following you
ever since your first first multilingual
video greetings from bot colia thank you
very much Sal is a nice town but I've
never been there where can we find
bilingual text except Asim that's a good
question basan CL Clement CL
Bas um the answer is I'm not 100% sure
in the sense that it depends on what
kind of material you're looking for if
you're looking for materials for
beginners that's one thing if you're
looking for materials in general for I
don't know say A2 B1 you can craft them
yourself you can create them yourself
you can take any transcript nowadays you
the amazing thing is that with AI and
the tools that we have you can do
anything you want you can take a YouTube
video without subtitles you can create
your own transcription you can take that
transcription and translate it with
Google translate if you want to just
just to name one deep l it's another one
very powerful you can use Interlinear
like there's another um tool that I use
in order to create Interlinear text one
in a target language one in my native
language I I have a video that describes
how to do that so you can do anything uh
when it comes to creating your own
bilingual texts and uh as for beginners
like language learning material for
beginners they have bilingual text I
know Asimo I know a couple of others but
in general I use Asimo as a reference
again if you want you can always create
your own bilingual text talking about
chat GPT can create tables bilingual
table just
saying so um Frank M already okay I
already read this question about
learning vocabulary I'm going through
the the old questions again what are the
colorful books on your shelves behind
you please short stories in different
languages I'm not sure what you're
talking about but if you're talking
about these this is geopolitics so I
organize things like this is like for um
if you guys want I can do this one live
maybe a YouTube video where I'm going to
show you the different um you know books
that I have in the library this is
fantasy Terry Brooks I don't know if you
ever heard of Terry Brooks then you have
uh you know Stephen King and you have
Bill Bryson here Jared tolken then we
have a lot of stuff uh here there's a
lot of Stephen King as well I have this
book I bought this book in 3,000
languages you can see this this is it
in Russian and I have it in 10 other
languages some people have Harry Potter
I have it and then I have recently my
Vietnamese friend has bought these I'm
really interested in learning Vietnamese
so uh he brought these as my birthday
gift that was very interesting if you
guys are interested we can do a special
show just for the library and I can go
through the library because I have
hundreds of books this is just now here
but I have hundreds of books everywhere
you should see it's it's it's even too
much
um so and by the way to answer your
question we talking about this
specifically this is liis It's called
liis it's a it's a geopolitics it's
called lemus you can see here this is uh
geopolitics I'm really passionate about
geopolitics and so I love this this is
an Italian magazine uh that comes out
every month and I I basically read all
of them so let me go down here um
he's asking me what language I have in
Hungarian I would say a solid B1 um
depending B1 B2 I can have free
conversations and uh you know I I was in
recently in October in Budapest and I
had a great time especially when you
know a taxi drivers at the beginning I
this guy didn't speak a word of Italian
sorry a word of English I had to explain
I want to you know um a receipt for my
company and so I was very proud that I I
I did that because it was very technical
for some technical things and then um on
my way to the airport back to Rome I
talked for 30 minutes 45 minutes just in
hungan about pretty much everything with
another Taxi Driver he's really nice and
when you get into the flow and you focus
more on communication rather than you
know thinking whether you made a mistake
or not and thinking about whether you
conjugated that verb or that verb
correctly everything uh turns into magic
so to speak so uh we're we we very often
underestimate how how good our language
skills actually are sometimes because we
tend to focus more on whether we're
performing well or not and that keeps us
from expressing ourselves to the best of
our
possibilities so um taist asks in
Spanish I'm going to translate
directly uh if I um can do a video about
active
versus um passive uh reading by the way
I wanted to tell you before I answer
this question uh actually the answer is
yes we I will make this video I always
use these wonderful questions that you
ask me to create new ideas for a new
video so keep
asking because even if I don't reply to
all of them then I'm going to review all
of the questions and I'm just going to
go oh this is a very interesting thing
this is a very interesting thing that I
can talk about Etc so this active versus
passive reading we intensive versus
extensive I I'll I have already a video
about that actually to tell you the
truth I have one video about intensive
reading one video about extensive
reading and that article that I wrote
the relative article is the most popular
article on my blog so if you write um
intensive versus extensive reading on
Google Luca lello you will find the you
will find the article and you will find
also the corresponding videos if you
want to go deeper into this
wonderful uh you know uh
subject so let me see
um have you ever Fabi
asks do you get tired of language rning
basically so he's saying basically this
happens to me with English I really like
speaking it but I don't like learning
new things like a maybe I guess you mean
reading or listening to stuff the answer
is no I have never gotten bored of
language learning I would do this
forever but but I would like to do other
things it's not just language learning I
have other things that I do in my real
in my normal life and I don't talk about
it I'm really passion about astronomy
for example astronomy geopolitics
history and I do a bunch of other things
so language learning is is an important
part of my life but it's on the only one
it's one of the many things interest
that I have um so but in general no I
don't get bored because I use the
language to do something meaningful so
to me anything that you do when you
learn a language you explore another
world and I think it's cool uh you know
it's it's it's cool there's can you find
something cooler than learning new stuff
I don't so I never get bored of learning
uh stuff I can get frustrated but not
bored I can get frustrated if sometimes
for example with um Japanese I found it
frustrating at the beginning because I
couldn't understand it was too difficult
I couldn't speak or when I used to speak
with my tutor was a mess my brain is
fried every time I try to express myself
I just try to try to say one simple
thing in Japanese because I was using
the wrong approach so frustration yes
but boredom
nope so um let me see
um so em
ask
so someone is saying Emy she's saying
she's asking in French she she started
the by Direction translation course
which uh one of the courses that we have
for beginners and she asks if she can
use the method with um basically novels
with books uh and then she asks or
should I have explan grammar
explanations my answer is that you
should use the B directional translation
with simple short dialogues for
beginners so you you can use the B
Direction translation in different ways
but I would not recommend it I would not
recommend using books in order to do
this by Direction translation the way I
use it this form of the B diretion
translation is used only for beginners
and you said you are a beginner to
possibly uh content like this so you
just to give an example um you let's say
you start learning I don't Hungarian
just one random example and as you can
see here
uh this is very very short so you have
but you know you have you have here
uh you see how short these dialogs are
there's just eight lines so you should
you should use the B directional
translation just with very short texts
because the B directional translation is
taxing it's not easy um and it requires
a lot of concentration if you use a a
you know a novel or a book for which you
don't even have grammar explanations
good luck with that so stick to simple
language learning material for beginners
when it comes to applying laity or the B
Direction translation method and thank
you for signing up to uh the uh you know
to our school one more as I as I
promised for those who have come just
now the announcement is that we have um
brand we have I have with my team
crafted a brand um
new ebook and we're offering it just
sign up to the newsletter and you will
get the immediately after a few minutes
you will get an email where you can
download the the ebook that comes uh in
PDF format ePub if you just want to use
Kindle or any other device maybe your
phone your iPhone and an Audi book it's
90 minutes long where I talk and I
basically read the entire book so you
can read it you can read it anywhere you
want with any device you can read and
listen to it or you can just listen to
it complet
free so this is a gift that we uh wanted
to give to and you know if you subscribe
to the school or the smart language
running School we're sending you this
gift anyway and to those who are signing
up to the newsletter uh these days so
let's go back to the
questions uh let me see did you use
methods uh by Steve Kaufman Steve
Kaufman uh for those who don't know is a
very famous polygit a fantastic guy
we've met a couple of times at these uh
um you know language learning um
language learning events and yes I have
used let me just show you
here while I'm at it while I'm I'm
here so this is an example this is link
or link you uh this is a text that I
created so I just got the the relevant
stuff from his website and then I and I
as you can see here I this is Chinese I
created this is Ping Ying so it's a
transliteration of the Chinese
characters and then I have the
translation and um when I so I didn't
use so much the methods but rather his
uh website you can see here this I did
15 years ago and this is back in the day
when I didn't have you can see here
maybe back in the day where I didn't
have translation tools like we we we do
now and basically what I did is
painstakingly Let me Give an example wow
this is it's been a long
time I know this is mattness you
probably can see this but what I did is
basically I listened to the stuff and I
was looking um I was painstakingly
looking up every single uh you know uh
well not character by words from
vocabulary and I loved it I loved every
second it I did it for a year and a half
and I gotten very good at Chinese and
speaking Chinese and then then I dropped
it but yes so to answer your question
Steve Koffman has a wonderful website
which is called link you they offer more
and more languages and uh I subscribe to
his philosophy of massive input and you
can find a lot of interesting content on
his
website so um
and
I can say I can speak I can say
something any time but then the others
are going to get lost if you guys want
no actually it's not if you guys want we
will do this there's a live show that
I'm going to do with a friend so uh stay
tuned because it's going to be fun and
we're going to do some stuff all for all
those who are interested in Italian
we're just going to be speaking Italian
for an hour or an hour and a
half so let me
see let me see if there's some other
interesting question
question
um what do you think about just watching
movies of different levels without
studying the language could I become
fluent in this way or not it would be
more pleasant junino asks that's an
excellent question my answer is yes you
can but if the language is very distant
from your own language then it's going
to be tough uh an example there's a guy
who watched I don't remember the name he
was a YouTuber I don't even know if he's
got a YouTube com uh cont sorry if you
has got a YouTube channel right now but
what he did is he he watched uh Chinese
TV for 10,000 hours at the end he could
understand just a few words and the
reason why is that that's not
comprehensible content in order to
understand you have to go through
comprehensible content so uh that's one
thing the second thing is that if the
language you're learning is very close
to your own native language then
watching television uh could be a good
solution because you're going to
understand more and
more say if you want to learn Italian
and if you're a Portuguese a native
Portuguese speaker then that could be a
way to go because since the two
languages are very close you don't need
so so many grammar explanations but the
more distant the languages the more
grammar explanations you need in order
to dissect and understand the points
that you will not figure out yourself
just by comparing the structure of each
sentence so um so that's that's the
answer uh uh so if you want to go and
try if you're learning a language that
is not that distant to a your own native
language or any other language you have
under your belt just give it a try but
normally I would rather spend three to
six months doing something with these
kind of materials that I have here that
I've shown you here in order to
understand how the language works then
you can jump uh jump in the more
authentic content and fun like watching
movies but you need a base as an adult
you need to understand how the language
works if you just try to use authentic
content for the sake of consuming
content that is cool then you're not
going to learn much you're going to get
lost and you're going to get frustrated
you don't want that to happen
so let me see
umand
asks
basts so he's asking if I like um
languages where actors speak in multiple
languages Eng glorious bastard is a
fantastic movie I watched it multiple
times and the answer is yes as for other
recommendations nothing come to comes to
mind but I'm pretty sure if you write on
Google or on chat GPT give me movies
give me a list of movies where people
speak in multiple languages Chad GPT and
or uh Google they're gonna spout a lot
of a lot of
stuff g b you've taken multiple
proficiency tests would you recommend
them for those wishing to improve the
language skills my answer is yes I would
recommend taking tests and if it's not
you know a lot of people a lot of my
students a lot of students of the
Academy have taken tests and they've
come to the community they said we'
we've managed to pass this test and this
test we're very proud some some people
did not pass uh the tests but even if
you don't pass a test right you have
learned something it's all we're always
you know very attached to uh results but
the we're rarely attached to the process
and the process whenever you take a test
you learn something right I remember my
own frustration in school when I was
like doing this engineering uh
University and um for example I flunked
a couple of times um a test I have all
the engineering books down there and my
father just told me look you've learned
something right even if you flunk a test
you've learned that's the process the
process you have to be process attached
not goal attached so when answer is yes
if you want to um let's say if you have
a B1 and you want to improve well it's
great to have a test because that test
is going to force you to do stuff you
will not normally do by yourself that's
the that's the tricky part when you
reach the so-called upper exellence of
language learning when you're getting
towards a B2 then reaching a C1 still
need some discipline and some
organization and planning and most
people they go like okay I already speak
a language at a B2 level I can already
communicate I'm functional in the
language why would I just Embark upon a
quest where I have to sweat and through
toil and sweat I have to you know try to
improve my skills and most people just
they say Well they're very happy with
the level they have and that's where
having language proficiency tests can
really make a difference I remember I
had a lot of fun when I did these uh and
they pushed me to do stuff I remember
especially for the German one I was a
little bit worried it was in 20 uh 2010
I think it was like 13 or 14 years ago
and I talked to Richard Richard simut
the world Fame polygod and I remember
Richard was kind enough to tell me
lukino you have to pass the test I'll
help you with that and we hopped on a
call and we were speaking German every
single day for like a two or three
months so that in and of itself the fact
that I had a proficiency test looming
right there just like in a few months
just forced me to write a journal in
German to speak with Richard every day
to do to write formal letters and so I
think proficiency tests can uh really
make a difference I've made a video
about that if you're right tests are
tests good for language or something
like that L larell on YouTube the
magical you the keywords you will find
that video So my answer is
yes um Frank
askas so Frank asks if English is still
the most important language when it
comes to the business world and the
answer would be resounding yes you have
to learn English you have to speak
English well in this world if you want
to function in in a if you want to
function in this world otherwise you're
cut from from a lot of stuff not just
business uh so uh Abid language learning
Luka do you think being an English
speaker makes it harder to learn a
foreign language what are your thoughts
I've made an entire video about that and
in and you can find it is like I don't
remember the exact um title but it's
something along the lines of uh is
English keeping you from learning other
languages or something like that and my
answer is yes and no it really depends
uh and Depends dep on your attitude if
someone for example say you go to you go
to Holland or you go to Sweden you start
speaking Dutch or you start speaking
Swedish and they get back to you and
they speak English then it's a little
bit frustrating that can happen and also
ourselves sometimes for example I was
living with this Greek guy here and most
of the time we're speaking English even
if uh we could have spoken U um Greek
antoniio I think Anton is probably
watching this he told me that he will
watch it and we were speaking I I would
say 60% English um 30% um Greek and 10%
Swedish sometimes rarely uh but the
answer like it was also my fault in the
sense that sometimes I was tired even if
I speak Greek um I think fluently now I
was tired and I told myself you know
what let's speak English and also when
we were like sitting with other people
we're not speaking Greek because other
people will not understand so there's a
number of problems connected with the
fact that English is the dominant
language and sometimes we are B we are
Al also a little bit uh you know lazy
uh sometimes we're in a group and we
have to speak English and sometimes um
you know certain peoples or populations
speak English so well that it's
different it's difficult to use and
practice their own language Sweden or
Holland this they're too glaring example
of examples of that so in a way yes in
another way if you really are committed
to learning and using your target
language you can just tell please I've
seen this uh you know uh I've seen
Richard in particular Richard simut the
wonderful fed World Fame polyon do this
like please I want to practice your own
your your language let me speak your
language so it's it's also it's a it's a
common problem at also your own personal
attitude it depends on a number of
factors so um Bastian CL he asks another
question in
French so in order to improve your
pronunciation do you learn all the all
the sounds existing in the language or
do you repeat just the words that you
that you hear well the answer basal is
um a
little it's a little bit complex but the
the bottom line is that I pay first of
all I listen and read a lot at the very
beginning I pay attention to
pronunciation and intonation so the
sound structural role the sound
structure of the language and of a
sentence not just the single Parts as
kids do they it's just listen to how s
like sentences sound my brain starts
picking up the patterns I listen
massively to the language and I pay
attention after a little bit my brain
starts picking up patterns I speak and
then I pay attention to Corrections that
the tutors especially tutors that I pay
higher tutors give me in terms of
pronunciation and intonation and then I
take it inst stride I use that feedback
to further improve my pronunciation and
intonation one recent um example in this
regard is is my friend Alex is Serbian
and we had a conversation in Serbian for
20 minutes and he goes like your Serbian
sounds a little bit like Russian and I
went like okay well it's a little bit
disappointing but at the same time I
didn't even knowa no I didn't even
realize I used to say instead of Z so
that's another sound just an
example like I like something and um you
know I pay attention but as much as I I
I can pay all the attention in the world
that some things elude me because I'm an
adult and um you know I'm I'm not a I'm
not a child I'm not my my brain is not
as plastic as that of a child so I do
miss stuff but um I think if you set
your ego aside then you realize that you
know you're a human being and you make
mistakes and you take it in stride and
you learn and you incorporate the the
the feedback into your speaking patterns
and pronunciation patterns then you keep
improving so in a nutshell to answer
your question it's very important to
start from the very beginning to pay
attention ention to be interested to
want to sound like a native speaker to
blend in psychologically to belong to
another tribe the psychological aspect
it's really important you have to pay
attention you have to listen massively
to the language either through reading
or just listening and then you can uh
apply what you learn in terms of like
sound structures and it's really
important to pay attention to the
feedback that you get from native
speakers that you can pay or if you find
someone that does it for free even
better and then you keep improving upon
the corrections and the feedback that
you get along the
way so that's it uh in a nutshell uh let
me see there's there's a lot of stuff
here
um yoga says Alejandro you keep
repeating your comment I'm sure Luka
will see it when he gets a
chance um Alejandro been learning
English and Russian for many years my
Russian has got much better over the
years but at the same time it has
interfered with my Eng English and kind
of ruined by English accent any advice
well my my my piece of advice is to make
sure that you practice both languages uh
regularly when you start when there's a
let's
say you a new language comes to the four
and you start practicing one language
much more listen to one language much
more than the other then the other one
suffer so my piece of advice simple
piece of advice is to um assess where
you stand in terms of English and
Russian and uh how many hours and and
tell yourself how many hours do I spend
doing this with English how many hours
do I spend doing this for Russian and
trying to find a balance so that you're
telling your brain that both Russian and
English are important otherwi otherwise
one becomes more prominent in your brain
and starts interfering with the with the
other uh what is a nutshell different
interesting well in a nutshell you know
it's an expression in English I use it
all the time um so uh
[Music]
um dra says kids make pronunciation
mistakes a lot so they're not perfect
repeating ma perfectly repeating
machines that don't notice everything
they do eventually become perfectly
competent but it takes a lot of time
that's absolutely correct and I am not
even sure if they become perfectly
competent it depends on what you mean by
perfectly competent but the the the the
matter is that we tend to forget we tend
to say oh you learn like a kid so you
speak like an any speaker yes but a lot
of children make a lot of mistakes a
seen at first stand for example they
make mistakes depending on the language
the and uh they get Corrections and then
um they learn naturally but we we don't
have to forget that we as kids and also
teenagers be making a lot of mistakes
and we have the advantage and the luxury
of having our parents and our peers
correct and our teachers correcting us
and then we we tend to forget that and
again the difference between children
and adults or adults is a m it's a is
the fact that children they have not
unlearned yet how to communicate if
efficiently well adults unfortunately
have we don't communicate effectively we
have to we have unlearned how to do that
and we have to relearn learn again how
to do that properly focusing on
communication rather than performance
remember guys and girls we all have gone
to school most of us
hopefully but we there we have learned
that we we've learned to be competitive
we've learned to think oh he's done
better than me I have to um you know
perform better I have to do well I have
to pronounce things well I have to uh
avoid mistakes that's delarius that's
not what you want to do when you want to
speak a foreign language it's a joy to
communicate with other people whether
you make mistakes or not and native
speakers are very forgiving they're
going to love the fact you speak their
own native language and most of the
things of the fears we we have we Harbor
uh will depend on us their own in our
own mind you
know so uh yeah yoga Bliss dance she's a
student uh she's a student or beloved
student or our school says it's a
colloquialism of slang for in brief like
in a nutshells like in brief thank you
for the uh thank you for the um
explanation so um we have still 30
minutes to
go uh let me see here um yeah I'm
looking at the
bottom uh let me
see Mega City Patrol well kids have the
ultimate in total immersion that's
exactly
right uh fa asks
luk do you have any product which allows
to learn English from scratch yes we do
it's called a b dire translation and
again you can find it here just going to
link uh that's a website where you can
find B directional translation is for
beginners uh the overcoming the
intermediate Plateau if is for
intermediate Learners and the Bor and
translation comes with subtitles in
English Italian French Spanish Russian
and I even think Portuguese so um and we
also have uh the corresponding U like
the same stuff but in Spanish so uh
that's called a b translation you can
use it it's a it's a technique that you
can use to learn pretty much any
language including and especially
English so
um let me see
here um
let me go up now there's a lot of
questions as always I'm sorry if I
skipped some but um Carlos what are the
four languages you're taking now
Luka Greek Hungarian Serbian and Tada
Turkish which I'm going to start
learning on the 1st of January and we're
setting up the three-month challenge uh
for the in the in the school so this
these are recurring three month
challenges that we run the first one
starts uh for for the by Direction
translations of course for beginners uh
it's going to start on 1st of January
and since it's a public commitment I'm
very excited about it because when this
is public and I'm like the the owner and
the founder of the school I have to set
the example so I will learn like I did
last year with I think two years ago
with Serbian every single day for 90
days and then we'll see what happens so
I'm going to use I don't have it here I
have it in the other room Turkish Asimo
Turkish I'm going to be using Asimo
Turkish for 90 days covering the first
90 lessons and then we'll see normally
after 90 days I get bored and I move on
to the techniques in the other course
which is the the course for low
intermediate Learners or intermediate
Learners so let me see here on the iPad
um so how would you include or
incorporate downtime time off in
language study for beginners um I
would as a beginner I think it's really
important to spend at least 30 minutes
doing some deliberate learning
deliberate time then um you can anchor
10 minutes of just say listening to
stuff that you've already gone through
while sitting down and you can anchor it
with other habits that you have maybe
you just walk the dog and can take 10
minutes to listen to stuff you've
previously uh worked through and gone
through so there's always a way to
incorporate language learning uh in
simple mode I would say just especially
listening when you run some errands or
you do other things during the day
that's that's my answer so I would spend
30 to 45 minutes sitting down and and
really trying to grasp and understand
and figure out the patterns of The
Language by sitting down comparing texts
reading and listening and then use that
knowledge the more the more units you
cover the more you're going to learn and
you can use uh you can go back and you
know while running some errands you can
listen to uh the audio relative to the
units of content that you've covered by
sitting down so you are the best you get
the best of both worlds so to speak it's
a little bit more complex than that but
I try to make it simple since I have to
answer a lot of other
questions so um let me see um Osvaldo
says how much could be the cost of being
your student online well I don't do
coaching anymore I have a lot of
requests every day uh in terms of can
you be my coach and the answer is I love
to but I I I'm I'm selling online
courses right now so what we're doing is
that I I TR I let's say I transition
from um coach private coach because that
was um you know I I can help people but
not as many as now because you know now
I have an online school where I have
courses and we have a community and a
lot of students are already here I can
see some of the names and um I I believe
that apart from the information that you
get from the courses which is valuable
the the the I would say the biggest
value in the community and more and more
people are telling me more and more
students are writing to me privately and
saying what really makes a difference is
that to see other Learners learn to be
in this like sometimes we feel alone we
feel lonely we have doubts we have
limiting beliefs about ourselves but
when we see that there there's other
people have the same limiting beliefs
they're going through the same struggles
or similar victories you know it's
beautiful to share to celebrate the
struggles the victories and also the
limiting beliefs and you know to realize
oh I'm not alone oh this guy or this
girl thinks exactly the same as going
through exactly the same thing I'm going
through so that is the value um I think
of the community and of the of the the
online if you guys are interested again
you can go to my website and there's uh
courses there you can take the courses
and you get uh you you you automatically
become part of the school and you get
access to the entire community and
everything that beyond
that um so let me
see uh uh let me
see when you get to C2 it means you're
able to watch videos with no captions
well fundamentally yes but there's
always videos that are difficult to
understand even for native speakers so
for example if an American watches a uh
a movie in Scottish I'm pretty sure
they're going to find it difficult to
understand everything like train
spotting I don't know if you ever heard
of train spotting and so I I always use
subtitles anyway
regardless um Deco 6 how do you manage
learning so many languages at once as
you mentioned you're now learning four
Lang languages how do you use or repeat
other languages you speak or used to
learn in the past so this is a very
interesting question and I divide my
language learning or the languages that
I have under my belt into two categories
you have uh let's say system one and
system two system one is the languages
that I speak fluently U let's say I am a
language user so I have a level that is
higher or like B2 or higher and this
allows me to basically use the language
to listen to I don't know the news as a
native speaker would and then I have the
languages that I'm still learning
actively so I have around uh let's say
eight or nine languages that for which I
have a level that allows me to just use
these languages in everyday life and
because of various life circumstances I
can use at least let's say between five
unfor like unfortunate day five if if if
the day is pretty lucky and it's pretty
productive language wise I can use 10 so
I use these 10 and then uh these these
other four I spend around 30 minutes
each doing things that
uh for example for Greek I listen when I
go running or I do workouts then when I
take a shower I have my airpods and I
have to wash my hair I listen to 30
minutes of Greek that's 30 minutes of
one language then I sit down first thing
in the morning after um you know after
my morning routine and I do Turkish so I
always find ways to squeeze in uh two
two languages one two three languages a
day apart from the languages that I that
I use in real life U that I use in my
everyday life sorry
so again Italian French Spanish um
polish what else Italian English French
Spanish German polish Uh Russian not
that much these days but let's say six
six of these languages I either watch
the news or I talk to colleagues within
the the school or write to uh to to
people to you know students and at the
school or I read magazines I always find
ways of using these languages because
they've become part of my life so I'm
not sitting down to learn say Greek I'm
just using Greek in my everyday life so
that be that's a different mind it's
it's a different category it's a
different way of of of learning you're
still learning but you're using more
than learning I'm talking about Greek
but for Turkish I have to sit down and I
have to learn so starting from the 1 of
January I will sit down and I will learn
Turkish for an hour a day that's what I
have to do for the with a new boorn then
you have teenagers the rebellious
teenagers like Serbian or Hungarian
especially Serbian I think I have an A2
A2
B1 that's another language that requires
me sitting down and doing stuff and the
other languages I can I can just use
them even Hungarian I can I just started
watching Fredo's podcast it's called
it's a stuff that we're talk about
geopolitics they talk about religion
politics I love it has subtitles I can
watch it in hung subtitles in Hungarian
uh or English so again when you start
getting better and better with the
language it's less and less exhausting
to engage in activities that you find
cool and they don't it doesn't feel like
you're learning it feels like you're
just you know just enjoying something
consuming something for the joy and sake
of consuming uh that stuff in your
target
language so Teresa goes Lucas are you
alive who knew thees yes I'm live that
is another wonderful student within the
language learning academy and she
participates in all our Zoom chats um I
think that is you haven't missed one
since you've joined the school both in
English and in Spanish and uh I do this
live once a month more or less uh the
next one is probably going to be in
Italian so I've done most of them in
English I've done a couple in Spanish I
think the next one is going to be in
Italian correct yes that is I know
because we speak every month uh by the
way this is another feature that we have
um is we have zoom chats with me uh
normally there's I think between 20 and
30 students for the English for the one
in English and then we have for Spanish
normally 5 to 10 and they can talk to me
directly we always have wonderful
conversations and we talk about um you
know language learning again we share
struggles victories and it's always very
refreshing and very empowering to talk
to the students of the
school van of do Carlos asks
um I I don't know Carlos but I might
make one of dut also in German um but
again first English Spanish Italian
French and then German and then
maybe I'd like to make it in every
language uh that I
know okay um so uh we are approaching
the end uh I'd say we have 20 more
minutes um globos asks are you excited
about learning Turkish yes I am excited
about learning Turkish
um I love to learn um again I know it's
a difficult language but I'm going to
try my best to learn every day and I
think that if you learn every day and
you're passionate about what you do then
the magic will happen sooner or later
I've heard that Turkish is pretty tough
but we'll see the the the interesting
thing about Turkish is that the syntax
is very similar to Japanese and Japanese
was my let's say best we say any time it
was my it was a tough nut to crack uh
but now I know how to tackle this
problem of of a different syntax so
using the B directional translation so
we'll see what that gives
um
so um what do you think of fluent U I
have no clue Anita because I've never
used it so um that's my that's my answer
I don't know if you can give it a try if
you like it I don't know if you guys
have used fluent U there's a lot of apps
out there that are that are interesting
but I always say that if you find
language rning material that has
interesting content print it or buy
something that you can you know touch
you can hold you can leave through and
you can even smell because that's
contact to the real world we need
contact with the real world with stuff
real real life objects and not just
platforms again I don't know fluence you
as a platform or an app I've heard about
this before but I've never gotten into
it but again you can use it if you want
but it's always in conjunction with
something else do you use aim in Italian
late ant asks yes possibly if it's in
Italian use it in Italian but if I find
it in other languages like an example
the example before Hungarian with these
you couldn't find an Italian I had to
use English and that's fine some for
some aim versions I have French Swedish
it was in French uh I think Dutch was in
French as well so you have to make do as
they
say um so Tana do you think it's useful
to use always subtitles Subs on
listening comprehension like listening
French with French subtitles I I again
if if you listen to something and you
don't understand it and when you watch
it or listen to it and you have lyrics
you have subtitles you have a trans
transcript that allows you to understand
what you listen to well that that's a
blessing and you should use that uh
aleandra says it's Luca not Lucas yes
it's correct it's interesting anecdote
in French uh when they sent me an email
it it was always wrong
uh and I never got emails because they
say Luca right and they thought it was
Luca l u c a s but no it's not Luca with
s it's l s without s it's a funny thing
when I used to live in France it
happened all the
time
um Jackson what is the best way to learn
cerlic language for an A1 learner I'm
trying to learn Ukrainian well my
suggestion Jackson this is another
suggestion where we have there's an
entire the entire demonstration I I
demon how to do this in one of the demo
videos uh in the by Direction
translation course is to create to um to
print a layout so you just can Google
cilic uh Ukrainian or cilic Russian and
you can find a layout right very easily
if you click on you know Google images
and then you just print it you have it
next to you you you download the
keyboard or you configure the keyboard
on your on your computer and then you
have a great time and you have fun
typing words that you find in your
language learning material typing words
by using the the new configuration that
you can use you you can easily uh you
know um set up on your computer and you
have a layout a physical layout just in
front of you you can even buy some stuff
that you can apply directly on your on
your keyboard and then you'll learn my
sheer practice and it's fun I can tell
you it's fun used I use this method to
learn a lot of languages without uh uh
you know uh a Latin script and
everything is also included in the B
transation uh
course H let's see uh do you mix the
languages by mistake uh like you use
reali words when speaking Spanish the
thing that happens a lot is that when I
try to speak Italian English you know
English words or words in English come
to the FL in my head because English is
the language I use the most Italian is
still my native language but English is
a language I speak more fluently now
when when it comes especially when it
comes to talking about language learning
because I do it all the time so it's a
matter of using right the more you use a
language the more fluent you become even
if not necessarily more knowledgeable in
the sense Italian is still my native
language but English I think is
definitely the language that I speak the
most fluently now because of the sheer
amount of time uh quanti of time that I
spend using English in all its forms
writing speaking listening Etc
uh Nick how do you use chat JT for
language acquisition the answer is I'm
not using chat JP for language
acquisition I'm still using the the what
I consider the best uh way of learning
languages is just listening and reading
so I'm not creating stuff I'm not asking
chat GPT to create stuff for me I'm
still using the amount we we we have so
much stuff nowadays available without
using chat GPT that you know I I don't
think I need chat GPT for now I would
use chat GPT or I would use um
artificial intelligence tools when it
comes to speaking I would like to have
imagine a tutor who corrects me and who
talks to me right that would be cool
because uh he can correct me and he can
give me feedback and I don't have to
feel the stress of talking to a human
being who just like hey you've you've
made this mistake and this mistake again
going back to what I was saying before
still in our head the stuff because most
native native speakers are very
forgiving of our mistakes but still I
would use it that way not so much for
consuming content
what are you doing for New Year's Eve I
got going to have a bunch of friends
coming here and we're going to party on
my rooftop for a little bit it's going
to rain though so I guess that I don't
know if we're going to party on on the
rooftop um but uh we're going to party
here party I mean just like party is
just having a nice time having a a great
time here without getting drunk or
divorce you know I'm too old for
that uh so let's see
um now that you said you speak English
more from learning languages do you feel
your native language is worsening
forgetting words Etc I wouldn't go so
far as to say that it's worsening I
would I would I would say that when it
comes to fluency it's worsening in the
sense that um I cannot express myself as
I did before but this is just a matter
of lack of practice in the sense that if
I was asked for example to give a
conference in it timean speaking about
language learning
I would say that it would be okay it
would not be difficult but I'm pretty
sure that a lot of words uh in a lot of
English words would come to the four or
come to my mind when trying to speak
English and so I have two options either
to insert English words in my Italian
speech which is not well you know is
frowned upon in Italy and not only in
Italy uh depending on the circumstance
and the context or um I just should try
to make an effort and try to use just
Italian words or that's going to be
difficult so um any language including
yours can get worse if you don't use it
that's the bottom line you know so uh in
my case Italian I wouldn't go so far as
to say it's getting worse but again when
I speak uh Italian a lot of English
words come uh come to my mind um and
abon Li
say so someone's got a subscription to
Li
um It's a Wonderful uh magazine about
geopolitics I love it this is if you're
learning Italian or you've been learning
Italian for quite a while and you want
very high like like this is the the
language that is uh you know that they
use for in these magazines is very high
level very elegant very nice
so so let's see let me go back I'm going
to answer a couple of more questions and
then we're gonna uh we're gonna
we're going to close
it uh tza says do you announce this live
show anywhere I'm going up um I think I
announced it on YouTube and on my social
media thata but I didn't announce it in
the school maybe I can change that if
you're interested you missed that but
there's a lot of them you can rewatch
The the
recordings so let me
see
uh
D this name is difficult
rumar I guess where will this three
Monon language course take us um well
this this by translation takes you to a
level where you have a very solid
understanding of the language so in
three months you follow for example you
do you you you apply this by direct
calization to this um just an example if
you're learning Hungarian to one piece
of content you have a very good
understanding of the language and then
you have to use other techniques in
order to expand it to acquire it that's
always the the main point when people
talk about the bir directional
translation I've recently seen a forum
then they talk about that me and the
translation I think there's a big
misunderstanding when it comes to the
this this technique this technique is
not in order to speak fluently this is a
technique in order to dissect and
understand the the the structure of a of
a given language it gives you the
foundation that is going to propel you
towards the acquisition of the language
so in other words when you want to learn
any language you first have to
understand if people are obsessed with
memorizing things how can I memorize
words how can I memorize vocabulary
especially as a beginner forget about
memorizing and focus on understanding
the birir translation um method has the
Merit I think that allows you through
translation to understand how a language
works so understand the structure the
grammar the pronunciation Etc in a in an
unconscious way because conscious and
deliberate at the same time so in order
of language levels I would say it
doesn't take you to a B1 or B2 it takes
you to an A2 but that is the the I think
the the biggest advantages is once
you've done that then you can um you
know start using other techniques like
podcast you can download podcast listen
and read Etc and it facilitates the task
of acquiring Language by consuming
content that is uh at a higher level
that's that's the main
point so
um Faruk says how many Lang is a college
student can learn every day well it
depends on the college student I guess
there's a limit I would always say one
language is best two languages if you
have some time three languages if you're
crazy and four languages if you're
completely crazy like me so any
alternative to Asimo five star paying
says they don't have the Polish one in
my language um it's a good question I
don't have it here uh I would say for
Polish I would I would rather use real
life uh was it again real polish I would
just subscribe to real
polish. and uh subscribe to his VIP um
thing and you will get anything you need
just amazing just amazing real polish
what he offers nowadays from the
beginning we have our friend Alex here
how many languages will you speak at
your party Alex is my is my colleague so
we've been doing a lot of stuff
including writing the book together he's
help me writing the book He's a
wonderful person he's a wonderful guy
and he always asks very interesting
questions how many languages will you
speak at your party I think just Italian
and we have an Australian girl um my
friend Kelly so I think Italian and
English and that's that's enough I got
four four of my friends coming here four
five again few people because when I had
100 people at my apart my apartment that
was a complete mess and I don't want
that to happen again and then we have Co
so
um let me see uh how how do you stay
motivated when learning a language that
is too distant from any language you
speak I'm struggling with Korean Wallace
and gimar says this very interesting
question and the more distant the
language the more effort you have to put
in and you can it can get discouraging
my simple answer is I don't have a
recipe for everybody but I would just
say that one thing and I'm telling you
this because recently I've been thinking
about this especially with Serbian I was
a little bit I was feeling this friction
I was telling myself do I want to
continue learning Serbian and I I told
myself yes but I have to find something
that I'm excited about you know it could
be a TV show it could be a a girlfriend
a YouTube uh a YouTube video or a
YouTube series or a YouTube channel that
is really interesting and that so in
that regard I think you have to find a
way to um move from just you know
learning sitting down learning or trying
to learn to memorize words Etc to
something that excites you could be
going to going to Korea the mere idea of
going to Korea or watch a documentary
about Korea reading a book about Kore
Korean culture whatever it is but you
have to find a way a new way of uh you
know sparking this uh this interest
again so it's it's frustrating I
understand uh it takes a long time but
if you find creative ways to stay
motivated you have to realize you have
to learn to understand what motivates
you what excites you makes you tick
what you know uh what compels you that's
that's that's the key what resources do
you use for Greek late and says
interesting I used aseno Greek first and
then I used helenic it was podcast from
helenic University completely free you
can find them online and then I used pod
101 Greek pod 101 and then I started
using uh easy Greek super easy Greek um
and by the way Dimitri and marilena the
founders they are coming here in 10 days
they're going to stay in my place I'm
super excited because they're super cool
I met them in
Greece
so five more minutes
um let me see you have to come to Serbia
to find a Serbian girlfriend baranka
says that's true that's absolutely true
that's what our friend Alex says all the
time I have to be married with a serpent
girl if there's any serpent girl who's
interested I'm here I'm kidding of
course um what else
um okay guys so thank you very much uh I
think we're we're coming to a close uh
again I want just wanted to tell you uh
that we have um a new free ebook
completely free and I'm just GNA write
this again
here so there we
go we have uh this ebook is um you know
pretty long it comes with uh in in ePub
version format so you can put on your
Kindle it's in PDF and it comes comes as
an audio book I recorded this in a
recording studio so there's 1 hour uh 90
minutes of me talking and uh reading the
book you can read it you can listen and
read at the same time if you're learning
English and if you want to improve it
you can do anything with it and um
so I think you're going to like it
there's a lot of good stuff and it's
completely free all you need to do is to
sign up and uh download the package and
enjoy someone asks couple of you know uh
last questions someone asked if I have
Nim TB I have all his books but not here
I have it in the other Library TB is the
man how how many far says how many hours
do you spend with every language on a
daily basis it's really difficult to
quantify for system one and system two
two systems I talked about but in a in a
nutshell I spend all my all my day using
languages
so I I I quantify just the languages I'm
learning actively um so I would say
between one and two hours and for the
rest I just use all the languages I know
or at least between six and 10 every day
so I don't count it anymore
um what was the easiest language to
learn I would say Portuguese after
learning serban sorry after learning
Spanish that was the easiest language to
learn because it's pretty much the same
language but the pronunciation is a
little bit different different uh good
to go too do you think 30 minutes a day
enough for learning a language it
depends on what you mean by enough in
the sense that it depends on what you
want to do if you want to speak a
language fluently then with 30 minutes a
day it's going to take you say more time
so I would say that 30 minutes a day is
great to uh to learn regularly so sit
down 30 minutes is great you can squeeze
in 30 minutes every day but it's going
to take you a long time to learn a
language F especially if the language is
different from the language very distant
from the language from your own native
language or languages you have under
your belt
so it frequency and intensity you have
to learn every day you have to add in
intensity if you want to get there
faster you have to think it it think of
think of it this way um you have to
cover a path right and if you walk then
you cover that path in a certain amount
of time if you run you cover that path
in less time so it really depends
on what your goal is if you say if you
have a very specific goal say learning
to speak a language fluently to reach
conversational fluency in say two years
because let's say you're learning
Spanish and you're going to move to
Mexico then I would say that one the
very least one hour a day is the bare
minimum I would say one hour 45 minutes
to one hour a day is the bare minimum to
make tangible progress within a a
relatively reasonable amount of time 30
minutes is great but still it's great
it's better than zero it's better than
15 minutes or zero or one minute a day
but I I I think it's going to take you a
long time and the problem is that if the
patch if the path stretches for too long
then you get discouraged and dispirited
so that's that's my
answer thank you Mr Lelo please send us
an autograph picture at your earliest
convenience I will do that Alex of
course I will send you
picture um so let's see here Bales I'm
learning B learn Bengali look at very
many Bengali people in Italy that's
absolutely true I have met a lot of them
uh here
um so uh five more minutes just because
I like this I I love I love answering to
your
questions so he's asking if uh it's
important to have a you know some
reference maybe for for learning
pronunciation um
I yes um let me see see if I have it
here yes I do so this is for students as
well as for learners for teachers I
would say this is the the best book I
found as a teacher when I was teaching
phonetics especially American English
phonetics this is a great book I don't
know if it's visible it's called
practical phonetics and
phology it's a fantastic book for
students it's fantastic book for
teachers and um because it tackles oh
look what I found here it
tackles found I hav seen this long time
this is when I got 100,000
subscribers um because it tackles
intonation as well and intonation is is
a really important part of the language
there's a lot of dust here you can see
because I haven't used it in a long time
practical Fanatics and phology whether
you're a student whether you're a
teacher of English and you want to learn
more sorry let me see this again rout
ledge let me let me show you this is
rout L English engl language
introductions you should be able to see
this there it is Teresa asks is this
live chat recorded yes Thea she always
asked me after after our chat on Zoom if
I got some books she's always very um
you know curious about all the resources
and the answer is yes it's going to be
it's going to be live it's going to be
on YouTube in as soon as this is
finished um the the the you know the uh
the event the live I think it's going to
be there as well it depends on the
settings I think I set it up so that it
shows but I'm not I'm not 100% sure it
it should it should
appear so guys I think uh uh I think
that's it um to answer your question the
CH Live Chat is recorded meaning that
when you're going to watch this again
you're going to see the chat you know
you're going to see the chat as we're
seeing it now uh but it really depends
on on on my settings I don't remember if
I put it if if I if if I recorded it if
I'm recording it the right way I hope so
cross your fingers otherwise you can
just listen to this
recording
um uh must are you still going to start
learning Turkish on January 2024 yes and
we have the three month challenge
starting on the 1 of January we have the
the entire three- month challenge
already set up there's I think 50 people
participating 50 students so that's
exciting with the the school language
rning school and I'm very excited about
learning Turkish in January 2024 and in
2024 in
general so um I see there's many many
other questions as I said at the
beginning of this recording what I
normally do is that I go through the
chat the live chat again and I you know
these these questions are really are
great and they're really also useful uh
for me to come up with ideas for new
YouTube videos thank you for your your
um for your time for the wonderful uh
questions that you always ask for the
enthusiasm I wish you all a fantastic
20124 um and the other thing that I
wanted to tell you again is that we have
um this new book we've put in a lot of
time it's a gift it's a it's a free gift
that um we hope is going to propel your
language learning in 2024 you can find
it on my website all you need to do is
to sign up to the newsletter if you have
have already signed up to the newsletter
so you're already a member of the
newsletter we're going to send this uh
in a couple of days at the beginning of
the year so everybody's whether you
subscribe or not they're going to get it
but if you subscribe now there's more
gifts coming your way in January
2024 so again here is uh the website and
the reference to the audiobook um I
think that's it guys um thank you for
coming uh thank you for all the amazing
questions again and um sorry if I
skipped some of the questions but I
cannot answer anybody within uh the the
90 minute Mark but I try to do my best
and it's always nice to talk to you well
to talk to you too to see your wonderful
questions and your enthusiasm for
language reading have a fantastic day
night evening wherever you find yourself
on the globe and I wish you a very um
fruitful and successful 20 24 when it
comes to learning languages and when it
comes to life in general the next chat
that is is probably in a month but uh it
really depends on a number of things
it's probably going to be in Italian so
I will um I want to experiment with
these chats and um as I know that
English is the most international
language but I would like to make these
also in Italian French Spanish German
Russian and uh what have you thank you
very much have a fantastic evening uh
day and I'll see you in
chcha